[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 124
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, as always,
Melanie Warrick.
Hello, Melanie.
How are you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: Doing OK.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing all right.
I'm still coughing.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You're still coughing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm still coughing.
MELANIE WARRICK:
This will probably
happen all year from now on.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
Just don't make me laugh,
and everything will be fine.
MELANIE WARRICK: This is Mark.
Mark now operates
at coughing level.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
But yeah, this
week, super excited.
We have the VP of Infrastructure
for Google Cloud Platform,
Eric Brewer, joining us today.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, it
was fun talking with Eric.
He has a wide variety of
experiences and background,
in that he was one of the
key players in bringing
about Kubernetes--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I
actually didn't [INAUDIBLE]..
MELANIE WARRICK:
--and open sourcing.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Which
was super cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: It was.
But before we get into
the interview, as always,
we have our cool
things of the week,
and we have a
question of the week.
And this week's question is, if
I want to visualize the network
traffic between pod services
within my Kubernetes cluster,
is there an easy way to do this?
MARK MANDEL:
(WHISPERING) There is.
MELANIE WARRICK: Is there?
MARK MANDEL: Spoiler alert.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, no!
[ALARM BLARING]
But before we talk about that--
and that'll be at the end--
cool things of the week.
So you may have heard of Next.
Next is the big Cloud
event that we have--
the big Cloud conference that
we have on Google Cloud--
and it is officially
July 24 through the 26th.
Tickets are now available.
We'll have a link.
You should check it out.
And then I know we also have
some satellite Cloud Next
events that are coming up.
I guess it's best to say
Next, or is it Cloud Next?
I suspect marketing
will get me later.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, so the other
events that are coming up
is in London October 10 and
11, and then also in Tokyo
the 19th and 20th.
Can you register for
those dates already?
MARK MANDEL: You
can just sign up.
Just sign up, and
you'll get updates
on when things are
opening and stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Ah, it'll
tell you what's going to happen
and when, cool.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
We also announced that
Cloud SQL for Postgres
is now generally available
and ready for your production
workloads.
So pretty short
one, other than it's
just generally available, which
means you have an SLA now,
which is pretty great.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, it is.
And apparently,
while it was in beta
they added high availability
and replication,
which was allowing it to
have higher performance
instances with up to
416 gigabytes of RAM,
and they support 19
additional extensions.
What's also really
great about this
is that while Cloud SQL
for PostgreSQL was in beta,
they added high availability
and replication.
And something else
that's really interesting
is that they joined the
Google Cloud Business
Associate Agreement for
HIPAA-covered customers, which
is a big deal.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, very nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: The other
cool thing of the week is that
our previous cohost--
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: You
almost said old friend.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I know, totally.
MARK MANDEL: He's old, no.
Our--
MARK MANDEL: Good friend.
Our good friend.
MELANIE WARRICK: Our good friend
who has gone off into the world
and is doing amazing things,
Francesc-- who, of course,
was one of the original
founders of this podcast--
MARK MANDEL: Was he, though?
No, he was.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: I don't know.
That's between you and him.
I'm not getting in between that.
Anyways, they have written
this great blog post
because he was
working with trying
to call C functions from
BigQuery with WebAssembly.
And he was doing this
because he wanted
to make the data accessible for
others to be able to explore.
And they have terabytes
of data, and they
thought it would be
very cool if their data
sets could be made available
for anyone to easily analyze.
And so he's got this blog
post, explains how he does it.
And what's fun is that
he connected with one
of our colleagues,
[? Felipe, ?] who is well-versed
on the BigQuery space--
MARK MANDEL: Very much so.
MELANIE WARRICK: --and
they wrote up a blog post
as well to explain how
to make it go faster,
and especially when
you're running C and Rust
code at scale.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no, he
does these really cute tricks
with using [INAUDIBLE]
to basically embed C,
and then [? Felipe ?] also
does Rust code as well
to basically make it
run on top of BigQuery
using its JavaScript engine.
It's kind of neat, actually.
I'm kind of impressed with it.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's cool.
And anything else, Mark?
Because I think you might
want to talk about Kubernetes,
is that right?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
I haven't spoken about
Kubernetes for the last 30
seconds, so I should
bring that up.
Another fantastic teammate
of ours, Sandeep Dinesh,
has started a series around
Kubernetes best practices.
Kicking it off, he's talking
about how and why to build
small container images.
So he has a blog post that's
up on the Google Cloud
Blog talking about how to use
Alpine to build small images,
as well as using multi-step
docker build processes to also
help with that pipeline.
To go along with that, there's
also a series of YouTube videos
as well that you can watch.
And we'll link to all
that in the show notes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
and they're also linked
at the bottom of the blog.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Well, Mark, I think it's
time to go talk with Eric.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
go chat with Eric.
Today I am--
I guess the term would
possibly be a little bit giddy.
I'm sitting in a
small, confined room
here with Eric Brewer, VP of
Infrastructure here at Google.
Eric, how are you doing today?
ERIC BREWER: I am doing great.
Happy to be in the little room.
MARK MANDEL: Happy
to be in the room?
ERIC BREWER: It's awesome!
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, thanks
for coming to join us.
I know we want to talk about
some open source stuff,
some distributed system stuff.
But before we get
stuck into that,
can you tell us a little
bit about who you are,
what do you do here at Google,
a little bit of your background?
ERIC BREWER: Sure.
I am, prior to Google,
best known as faculty
at UC Berkeley in
computer science.
And out of that work,
I founded a company
called Inktomi, which did
search engines before Google,
actually, and pioneered
a lot of the modern ways
that we actually build what
you now call cloud computing.
So for example, Inktomi
was the first company
to use large-scale
clusters in the style
that Google does now, and
pioneered that as a technology
for building
large-scale systems.
And then I've done a bunch of
work in developing countries.
And then for the last six
years, I've been VP at Google,
working on this second revisit
of all of the problems of cloud
computing.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
what does it mean
to be VP of Infrastructure?
ERIC BREWER: It's
a good question,
because I believe I'm the only
VP that has no direct reports.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK:
How does that work?
MARK MANDEL: So basically,
you do whatever you want.
ERIC BREWER: I am really a
senior architect for computing
for Google, both the cloud
part and the internal part,
and I view my role as to help
with the strategy of Google
Cloud, and also the tactics.
But in particular, what
is our tactical design
for how we want to build,
really, the next cloud?
And what we want
Cloud to be, versus
what it's been historically.
MARK MANDEL: And I believe
congratulations are in order.
You just won an award.
ERIC BREWER: I was,
yesterday, elected
to the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences,
which is founded by--
Thomas Jefferson and others
were the inaugural members.
And it's, I would say,
the US's elite association
for scientists and
artists, and also includes
business people, including
Larry and [? Sergey ?]
and several other Googlers, and
many people from Berkeley who
I know.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I
believe you also mentioned,
before we started the
podcast, that Barack Obama is
part of this?
ERIC BREWER: He is joining this
year as well, as a member, so.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we were
also talking about the fact
that you've actually met him.
ERIC BREWER: I have
met him a couple times.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
he offered you a job.
ERIC BREWER: Last
time I met him was
in October, about
three years ago,
when he did offer me a job.
And his point was he had
a year and a half to go,
maybe a little more, and he
felt the main way he could have
impact in that time-- because
Congress was a little bit
divisive--
was to work on agencies and
have the agencies make progress.
And he felt, correctly, that
they needed technical help.
And he recruited several people
from the Bay Area to do that.
I, in the end, declined--
in part because I like what I'm
doing at Google, but in part
because I have kids.
It was not a good
time to move to D.C.
But if I could serve
some other time,
I'd certainly consider it.
And I've also worked with
Bill Clinton in the past,
and so I'm familiar with
the general impact you can
have that way, which is great.
But I wasn't willing
to move this time.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you've
helped create USA.gov, too.
ERIC BREWER: That was the
project I did with Bill Clinton
in the year 2000.
And that was the first
federal search engine,
and covered all of the
US government properties
at that time.
That was a fun project for sure,
and he was a very interesting
guy to work with.
And then that expanded more,
in the past-- without my help--
to cover all the states
and include other things
like commerce and ID systems,
authentication for citizens
to get the government services.
It's quite a broad thing
now, but originally it
was really just a
fancy search engine
for all the federal content.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, speaking of history--
I didn't realize this, and I
feel a little ashamed that I
didn't-- you have a long
history with Kubernetes.
In fact, you were there
straight from the beginning.
Can you tell us a little bit
about your involvement there?
ERIC BREWER: Sure.
It started as a small project
with a few different people--
Brendan Burns, Joe
Beda, Craig McLuckie,
and some people that are
[INAUDIBLE] associated with it
now-- think people like
Brian Grant, Tim Hawkin.
My role was to help them
form it into something
that made sense for Google--
from a project--
and honestly, to
do extensive internal sales
to get Google on board
that Kubernetes was a
bet we needed to take,
and that it needed
to be open source.
And both of those were
controversial at the time.
MARK MANDEL: And so I'm
really curious, as well--
why, back then, did
you feel like this
was such an important project?
I mean, obviously, it
seems to have done OK now.
But in retrospect, I'd love
to see your perspective.
ERIC BREWER: I think
the reasoning was sound,
and I think the track
record proves that.
But the reasoning had
a couple of parts.
The first part is that the
cloud, especially then but even
now, is, in my mind,
way too focused
about the infrastructure--
the machines, the disks.
And that is not the
path to productivity.
The path to
productivity is thinking
about services and
APIs and how you
build things that
are highly available,
and you don't want to
worry about the machines.
You really don't even want
to know the machines exist,
frankly.
It'd be nice if we
could just pretend
they don't exist at all,
and Kubernetes is absolutely
a step in that direction.
So that was part of it,
and I would say my mission
at Google is to get the new
cloud to be something that's
about services and
APIs that has nothing
to do with infrastructure.
It's there.
We will manage it.
We'll make it secure.
But as a developer, you
shouldn't need to know.
The second aspect
is that it needed
to be open source, because
it's too big a shift for Google
to do by itself.
If we're going to change
the definition to cloud,
it has to be done
broadly, and open source
is the best way
to get that done.
And I think there's a
third aspect, which is--
if we make the playing field
about services and containers,
Google has a relative advantage.
If the playing field is
about virtual machines,
we can do that, but we started
very late in that game.
Whereas if you look at
containers, that's something
we've been doing for
a decade in Borg.
We have vastly more
experience on how
to do that than anyone else.
We literally invented
a bunch of the pieces
in Linux to make that
possible and understand them
more deeply than anyone else.
So we should be betting
on the places we can win,
and this is a place we can win.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
also had mentioned to us,
before we started, that you gave
the first talk on Kubernetes
ERIC BREWER: I gave the launch
talk at DockerCon in 2014.
We released Kubernetes that day.
I gave one of the two keynotes.
Solomon Hykes of Docker
gave the other one,
where he introduced
Swarm, which for a while
competed with Kubernetes.
But we had the
advantage that when
we talked about
Kubernetes, it was already
working to some degree, and
people could play with it.
And that really helped us
get off to a good start.
And frankly, it's well
designed, and it actually works.
And so that was a big
factor in it being
able to really take this space.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
And since then, our ecosystem,
especially at Google Cloud,
of open source tooling
has really grown.
We've got Istio.
We've got OpenCensus.
How do you see that
ecosystem going forward?
ERIC BREWER: I think it's
a core part of our strategy
to be the Open Cloud.
That was the talk I gave
at Next in 2016 or '17.
I can't remember which one.
I guess 2017.
But part of it is that we want
to make workloads more mobile.
That is to our advantage if
you use open source things that
can run on-prem, in other
clouds, and on Google.
Because now we're competing
on operations, on cost,
on technology.
And that's the battle
we want to compete in.
Right?
So open source inevitably
allows a couple
of things that
are helpful to us.
But the most important one in
my mind, besides community,
is that you can move workloads
more easily to GCP over time.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
And I know you're particularly
interested in Istio.
Can you explain where that
fits into the whole strategy
of where you're seeing
that workloads go?
ERIC BREWER: Istio has many
things I like about it,
but I think the way to think
about it is, really, it's
once you get a
little bit bigger,
you want to decouple the
operations of your clusters
from the developers who are
developing new services.
And the reason Istio does
this is, essentially,
that it's intercepting traffic
on its way into a service
so that you can automate
the telemetry you
get on every service.
You can automate policies
about access control and DDoS.
And so all the control things
you want to think about
for a service, you put in
the Istio layer and not,
in particular, in
the source code.
So we call this externalizing.
I'm saying, take
all the policy stuff
that you currently
have hidden somewhere
in the code of your micro
service, take it out.
Externalize it so that we can
manage those things from Istio.
And that has two big wins.
First is, it makes it consistent
for all your services,
because now you don't have
to update all your services
every time you want to change
a policy, which is intractable.
But also, as a
developer, it turns out
it makes you have more
freedom in the sense
that you don't have to
negotiate with operations
what the policy should be.
Right?
You worry about what
your service does.
Operations worries about
what the policies are.
And we remove this
friction that's
inherent if you have to--
on every call site--
actually agree
on what it is you're doing.
Right?
So we're taking out
coordination overhead,
which I don't think people will
appreciate till they have it.
But having been on both sides,
they will appreciate it.
MARK MANDEL: Hmm.
MELANIE WARRICK: In terms of the
next cloud, as you were saying,
what are you excited
about in terms
of what would be built off of
that once we get to a place
we're able to abstract more
of the actual back end?
ERIC BREWER: Well,
I actually feel
like people using
Kubernetes are already
getting a lot of this value
now in that if you're building
an application out of
a collection services,
and I mean, a good
example, Spotify.
Spotify was doing this model
before Kubernetes existed.
Right?
They had already kind
of bought into we
want to have APIs and services.
And they had built some in-house
stuff that was Kubernetes-like,
actually, to their credit.
But now we can give them
a much stronger platform
to do what they
always wanted to do.
And when you add
Istio, what that means
is that our operations
people can actually
manage a collection of
services versus managing
a collection of nodes.
Right?
So that even the
language they use
to talk about what
it is they've built
and how they're managing it
has been upleveled to something
that saves them a
lot of time and toil.
MARK MANDEL: There was a quote.
I'm going to attribute
it to Kelsey Hightower.
I think it was him that,
talking about Kubernetes,
is you deal with the
application layer and not
the infrastructure layer.
Does that sort of
resonate for you?
ERIC BREWER: Yes.
That is absolutely--
when I say new cloud,
I really mean you
should worry only
about the applications
and services
that you're trying to build.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What are the biggest
limitations that we have that--
barriers to the new cloud?
ERIC BREWER: Many
things, I would think.
First of all, there's a
whole bunch of legacy stuff
that is really about which
OS version do I need,
and how big do my
nodes have to be,
and how do I do
security patches?
Those are problems that
you shouldn't have to have,
I would say.
But there's a lot of
legacy tooling around
how you manage the actual nodes
and OS images you're using.
Right?
I would like that to just
disappear in some sense.
If you use GKE, it does
disappear, because we
manage the OS for you.
We do the security
patches for you.
But there's still a
lot of legacy stuff
that-- it works that
way, and tooling
and all kinds of things.
So that's part of the challenge.
I would say another challenge is
even the core pieces like Linux
itself, it kind of
expects you to deal
with devices for networking.
Right?
Other parts of the system,
like a file system,
is kind of easy to abstract.
You can make it look like
part of a process model.
The network and
devices, more generally,
are still very tied to the node.
So we're kind of
hindered by our legacy
use of nodes in various places.
But networking in devices is the
one that stands out most to me
at the moment.
And that's not easy to
fix, because changing
that requires changing a
whole bunch of open source
software that's using the
device-level interfaces,
IP tables, things like
that, that are inherently
part of the node.
And we will change
those things over time.
But that's not a quick process.
MARK MANDEL: Question
that comes to mind
is we talk a lot about
hybrid cloud, at Google Cloud
especially, especially
when we're talking
about things like Kubernetes.
How do you see
that new cloud-type
of strategy, or, like,
forward thinking,
working into hybrid
cloud-type scenarios?
ERIC BREWER: Well, we do see a
lot of people using Kubernetes
on-prem already.
And that is because
it's open source,
it was very easy for people
to try it, and play with it,
and use it themselves.
So a side effect
of that is we've
actually been building
allies inside companies
who are using
Kubernetes that will
want to move those workloads
to cloud over time.
And I am pretty
sure they'll find
that the best place to move
your Kubernetes workload
will be GCP.
All right?
GKE is still
significantly better
than any other
deployment of Kubernetes.
And it's managed for you.
And so if you just want to
focus on your application,
it's the best manifestation
of that vision so far.
MARK MANDEL: Is hybrid cloud--
I don't know if I want
to use this right term--
but I'll put it this way.
Do you think hybrid cloud
is an almost stepping stone
in the future of
cloud technologies,
like we have to go
through hybrid cloud
to get to maybe a full cloud?
Or do you think that's
probably just going to continue
to evolve, in terms of like--
ERIC BREWER: I think we--
MARK MANDEL: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIC BREWER: --have to
go through hybrid cloud.
And I think it's
not a quick process.
Moving to the cloud for a
large enterprise isn't--
not going to be a
single-day event.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC BREWER: Right?
It's going to be
a 10-year event.
And they'll move some workloads,
and later other workloads,
and they will use
multiple clouds, honestly.
That's fine.
But what it means is if you
want to preferentially get
future workloads to
move to your cloud,
you're better off interacting
with those workloads now.
Right?
So what I think about
it is every time
there's a Kubernetes
cluster on-prem
and we can help it
in a variety of ways,
that has a net present value to
us of being a future customer
load that's more
likely than average
to be on Google in the future.
We can disproportionately
win more
than our share of
those workloads.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I'm going
to play a little bit of a role
that Mark likes to
play on my podcast--
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: --that I drive.
What exactly is hybrid
cloud, for those
who may not know the term?
ERIC BREWER: It has a
few interpretations,
in part because
different vendors want
it to mean different things.
So it's always going to be a
little bit confused as a term.
But what we mean
by it is that you
can have some of your workloads
on-prem, some in our cloud,
some in another cloud.
And they start to feel like
one thing and not three things.
So an advantage to using
Kubernetes and Istio is
we can make these three
different environments feel
much more similar to each other,
And so for example, if you to
have a policy about which users
can access which
services, you can
enforce that policy
on our cloud,
on another cloud, and
on-prem in a consistent way.
That's what makes
it a hybrid cloud,
is the consistency
of policy that you
can expect to get over time.
Now, it does not always mean I'm
going to take a single workload
and split it across sites.
Sometimes that'll happen.
It's more common that you'll
partition your workloads,
and some will run here,
and some will run there,
and that you'll be in
the progress of migrating
some of them pretty much all
the time for the next 10 years.
Right?
It's a constant state
of evolving things
in a stepwise, safe way.
The other advantage hybrid
has, from my perspective,
is that there's a
variety of reasons
that certain workloads
can't move to cloud today.
Could be regulatory, it could be
certain concerns about locality
of data or latency,
or you don't have
a data center in the right place
for me, or we have sunk cost
and we need to use our
data centers for five more
years, all kinds of reasons.
And so there's an appetite to
modernize applications on-prem
using Kubernetes today
versus waiting five years,
go to cloud, and then modernize.
Right?
So part of the
hybrid strategy is
to decouple the
movement of cloud
from the modernization
of your apps.
You can now do them in any
order, and we'll help you.
And in fact, when
you have a portfolio,
you'll do a mix of
modernization and movement.
And you can control that
mix however you like.
MELANIE WARRICK: --as
modular as possible.
ERIC BREWER: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: You were
talking before about the value
of open source.
Do you think that there's
any specific things that
need to be done to help foster
a more comprehensive open source
community out there?
Anything specific around
the open source space
that you are very
passionate about
or find exciting about
where it's going?
ERIC BREWER: It's quite
a complicated space.
I would say we learn, despite
having done open source
for a decade, we're
still learning exactly
all of the best ways to
interact with open source.
But I will say Kubernetes, in
particular, has the strongest
community I've ever seen,
in terms of the rate of CLs,
the relative agreement on
kind of general direction,
and the extensibility, which
means that a lot of arguments
are avoided, because two
different players can
do the same thing
two different ways
and they're both compatible.
So the structure of Kubernetes,
both the technical structure,
but also the
community structure,
has been very effective.
And it's really a model, I
would say, for other communities
to try to follow.
And it's different, frankly,
than other open source efforts,
even within Google.
So for example, open source
can mean we release the source,
but we control it.
That's kind of
the Android model.
It can mean we
take pull requests,
but we have to
moderate them all.
That's kind of the
TensorFlow model.
And so it's still
fairly Googlecentric,
but open to submissions
of improvements.
Kubernetes model is much
more open than that.
It's really-- the community
is actually moderating
the important changes.
And we gave up the trademark,
meaning that the foundation
owns the trademark, not Google.
And the consequence of that,
which is very intentional,
is that we can't retract
the use of the trademark
just because you are
competing with us,
or just because we don't
like the way you're doing it.
Right?
So as an enterprise,
it kind of means
that you know Kubernetes
and your right
to use it is not revocable
at Google's whim.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
On a slightly different
track, is there
anything you're excited to learn
about in the next year or two?
Anything in particular
that you would
love to explore, especially
if you had the time for it?
ERIC BREWER: Sure.
I kind feel like I'm
consistently behind on machine
learning.
And it's not that I
don't know quite a bit
about machine learning.
I actually do.
It's another space that's
moving very quickly.
And I don't see how
anyone could keep up
with both Kubernetes
and machine learning
and do it have authentically.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agree
with you completely.
That's why we're both here.
ERIC BREWER: So I--
I have some homework
to do on that front.
And I have some
actual test projects
I'd like to do at some point.
But I'm not getting to them.
So we'll see where that goes.
MELANIE WARRICK: We'll
see when that happens.
By the time you
probably get to them,
something will have
been built to be
able to just automate it
for you, or take care of it
for you at that point.
ERIC BREWER: I can say
one funny thing, though,
which is that when I
learned about AI in school,
it was a kind of
a mess of a topic,
including expert systems.
But one of the topics was
neural nets, which then went out
of favor for quite a long time.
But it's one of the parts I know
better than others, because it
was still in favor when I
was taught the material.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
that's a good one
to know the way things
have been going lately.
ERIC BREWER: Turned
out to be pretty good.
Now that actually turned
out not to be that helpful,
because the field has
advanced so far that knowing
the basics of it is not as
relevant as one might expect,
but it's still kind of useful.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: That's great.
So I'm wondering--
looking forward,
and I'm guessing there's
obviously a lot of stuff
you can't talk about, but
are there particular areas,
either open source or at Google
that you think people should,
say, keep an eye on,
or that you think
are going to rapidly evolve in
a really positive direction?
ERIC BREWER: Well, certainly
the short-term ones
are there's a ton going
on in the hybrid space,
and particularly about how
do you create collections
of clusters that span
different environments
and that you can actually
manage as a single thing.
And again, that's something
that has to be done--
Google can lead it, but it
can't be done by Google alone.
It's a big project that
fundamentally is going
to involve a lot of partners.
And we'll see a lot of progress
on that this year, for sure.
MELANIE WARRICK: So we
know KubeCon is coming up.
And this is the big
Kubernetes conference.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that
and your involvement?
ERIC BREWER: This is KubeCon in
Europe in May, in particular.
And I've been to
many KubeCons, but I
haven't been to one in Europe
yet, so that'll be good.
Each continent has its own
kind of flavor of KubeCon,
so it'll be good to see what's
different about this one.
And that is one of the
reasons I'm attending.
There's a bunch of
things I care about.
So certainly the hybrid
stuff I care about.
I gave a talk in the
last KubeCon on that,
and there's more
coming on that front.
But also just, there's a ton
of stuff on machine learning
and Kubernetes, on aspects
of networking and management.
A lot more users are now in
production with Kubernetes,
so we'll hear some
of their stories.
So especially in Europe,
that'll be great.
But also honestly,
it's, again, hard
to keep up with this space.
And going to KubeCon
just forces me
to spend three days
deep in it and make
sure I'm caught up again.
MELANIE WARRICK: See what's
new and what's coming.
MARK MANDEL: What's been your
most exciting thing that you've
seen somebody either
extend or build
upon Kubernetes that you've
been like, that's really cool?
ERIC BREWER: That's
a good question.
Yeah.
I think-- one thing I
think is interesting
is people using clusters
that are disconnected
from the rest of the
internet as a way
to do a highly available
distributed system.
So if you want to run
something highly available,
and you are worried about
network connectivity,
having a local
Kubernetes cluster
turns out to be an
excellent way to do it.
And I've seen a--
I'm not sure which
customers I can talk about,
but you can kind of guess that
if you have an oil platform,
or you have a retail store
that's in a remote location,
you might want to have
some local computing that
can keep your store online
even if your network is down.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that's super cool.
I never actually
thought of that.
That's very cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
ERIC BREWER: And
Kubernetes, because it's
made to support
high availability,
is a very good fit for that.
MARK MANDEL: So that sounds
like a really great customer use
case for someone who
is using Kubernetes.
I know I do a lot of stuff
extending Kubernetes.
I think that the extension
mechanisms are really exciting.
Have you seen any particular
extension mechanisms
or the extension of
Kubernetes as a platform
for distributed systems
that you've thought
has been particularly inspiring?
ERIC BREWER: Well,
assuming you mean
CRDs as the extension
mechanism, which is this API
to have your own resources
with their own calls, that
is a fantastic mechanism.
And it's really, I
think, one of the secrets
to Kubernetes' success.
And it's a subtle one.
Because it's not something
you even necessarily learn
about the first few times
you play with Kubernetes.
But once you want to do
something with it that's
not what it does,
it comes into play.
And the real reason
it's an important part
is, again, it means it's much
easier for different players
to make different
changes and have
them feel Kubernetes is native
and have them work together.
MARK MANDEL: So for
those who don't know,
CRD, Custom Resource Definition.
ERIC BREWER: Custom
Resource Definition.
It's like you make
your own little nouns
and verbs that extend
the Kubernetes model.
But if you do it this way, then
all of the kind of Kubernetes
tooling, including the
Command Line Interface,
actually just support
your new extension.
And that makes it
very easy to integrate
into existing systems.
MARK MANDEL: Are there are
any particular examples
of that that come to mind?
ERIC BREWER: We're
using it, for example,
the way we want to
manage multiple clusters
is just an extension of that.
That's important
because, again, you're
going to have clusters on-prem
and in different clouds,
you'll need to
actually make sure
that you can manage them all.
I feel like anyone
that wants to do kind
of a functions-as-a-service
platform is going to want
to use that kind of extension.
Anyone that wants to do
a domain-specific version
of Kubernetes where you kind
of narrow the scope, let's say,
maybe it's for machine
learning, or maybe it's for--
I don't know-- for retail,
that actually ends up
being a way you can do that.
But I think the
main thing about it
is that because it
integrates with the tooling,
and because you can have many
of these things co-loaded,
it's very flexible and
avoids a lot of conflict.
MELANIE WARRICK: So in terms
of your career and the work
that you've done, who have
been some of the mentors,
or the people that you've
been inspired by, as you've
been going down your path?
ERIC BREWER: Mmm.
That's a great question.
And there's always a bunch.
And you never quite know
who it's going to be,
but let's see.
On the technical
side, I would say
three people that stand
out, technically, Butler
Lampson, who is
now at Microsoft,
but a famous computer scientist
and Turing Award winner who
was on my PhD committee at MIT.
Barbara Liskov, who was
my first adviser at MIT
and later won the Turing Award,
and one of the great women
in computer science, and
introduced a bunch of things
that we take for granted,
like abstraction,
the idea that you might want to
have an abstract notion of what
something does behind an API.
That's so obvious now, but
someone had to do that, right?
It doesn't come from nothing.
And in fact, I think she got
the Turing Award a little later
than she should have because
it was too obvious, which
is a totally unfair judgment.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
ERIC BREWER: And
actually, this year's
award winner, Dave Patterson,
who, one of the first faculty I
worked with in
detail at Berkeley.
I got to Berkeley in 1994,
worked on the NOW project,
which is about to have its 20th
anniversary, because we measure
the anniversaries from
the end of the project.
That's the project that
led to cluster computing
for the internet and
Inktomi, and was,
in some ways, the reason
I won the Sciences
Award, for that train of
work on cluster computing
and large-scale services.
And so that case,
it's not so much
that Dave was the
technical influence--
although he's
great technically--
it's that he is a
great leader and showed
how to do a group project
versus an individual project.
So the NOW project had
four faculty involved.
I was, in some sense, the
fourth, the junior guy.
And they were very
welcoming to me
and also just taught
me a lot about how
is it you do research, how
do you engage students,
how you get things
done that have impact,
and even what your
goals should be.
Right?
The goal should be impact.
And I've followed
that advice forever.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agree.
Any resources that you'd
recommend for anything that you
particularly find that you're
a fan of around the Kubernetes
space, around containers,
around distributed computing?
ERIC BREWER: Well, you
mentioned Kelsey Hightower.
So anything he says
is worth watching,
and I enjoy the
time I get with him.
And he's a nice complement
to me in the sense
that I have some academic
background he doesn't have--
not that he's not super sharp.
He is.
But he has a tremendous sense
of the on-the-ground reality
for Kubernetes.
And he can keep me honest
when I'm being a little too
ivory towerish.
MARK MANDEL: Right
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
ERIC BREWER: And so it's a
great relationship for me,
but also I feel
like it's something
everyone can benefit from.
And you often can make
Kubernetes, which is, frankly,
overly complicated-- we can
talk about that if you like--
he can show you the simple ways
to get to what you want to do.
And that is a true art.
MARK MANDEL:
Unfortunately, we're
heading up on the half hour.
But before we wrap up, is there
anything we haven't mentioned,
or anything you want to make
sure that is on the podcast
that our listeners hear about
before we finish off here?
ERIC BREWER: I guess I would say
that you should think about all
the toil that you have
in the job you might have
as a developer
and how much of it
we should be able to get rid
of over the next few years.
Right?
Because part of the
move to Kubernetes
is to reduce the toil.
And the simple things,
we can already do,
like you're less
aware of your node,
and we can patch the OS for you.
But we should be able to
automate a bunch of things,
like we're looking at automating
the testing process much more.
And maybe we can
tell, you know, you're
running a bad
version of open SSL.
You might want to
get rid of that.
Right?
That's something
we can scan for,
and we should be
able to tell you.
And maybe, if you'll let
us, we can automatically
patch that too.
All right?
So there's a degree
of automation
that's possible when you get to
this higher-level abstraction
that's not possible
if all you have
is the OS image in the nodes.
And that-- and by
the way, that also
enables a huge new
use of AI, which
is have the AI tell
us what changes you
should make to your thing.
Because we actually
now have data,
and we are talking at a
higher-level abstraction,
which helps reasoning of all
kinds, human and artificial.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: I agree.
That'll be a wonderful thing to
be able to have more automation
to help with that, as well.
Thank you again.
We really appreciate you
coming on to the podcast
and sharing all things
Kubernetes, containers,
distributed systems, and
hearing about your mentors, too.
That was wonderful.
Thank you.
ERIC BREWER: My pleasure.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
Eric, thank you again
for joining us on the podcast.
It was wonderful to hear
about open source distributed
systems.
Well, actually what I think
I enjoyed most about that
was hearing about
his mentors, too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that was cool, too.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Anyways, so Mark, if I want
to visualize the network
traffic between my pods
within a Kubernetes cluster,
is there an easy way to do this?
MARK MANDEL: There is
an easy way to do this.
MELANIE WARRICK: What?
MARK MANDEL: I have--
I've actually tweeted
about this a lot.
This is a secret presentation
weapon that I have.
Yeah.
So don't tell anybody.
[EERIE MUSIC]
SPEAKER 1: Shhh.
SPEAKER 2: Shhh.
SPEAKER 3: Yeah.
This is top secret
stuff here, all right.
Totally classified.
Don't tell anyone.
Not a soul.
[INTERPOSING VOICES] Shhh.
MARK MANDEL: Be very,
very quiet about it.
There is a great
open source project
from a company called
Weaveworks, where they have
a thing called Weave Scope.
And it's super pretty,
if nothing else.
Basically, you can install it on
top of your Kubernetes cluster,
or they have a managed
platform as well.
But what it gives you,
which is really nice,
is a really beautiful,
topographical visualization
of exactly what's happening
inside your cluster.
So it's seeing
pods, and services,
and all that kind of stuff.
But it also introspects
your network traffic,
so you can actually
see which systems
are talking to which
systems, which systems
are talking to the
public internet,
that kind of cool stuff.
And it just gives you
a really great way
to visualize exactly what's
happening inside your system
and whom is talking to whom.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like
it when I can actually
see what's going on, like
show you some visuals on that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So usually-- I use that a
lot when doing presentations,
because it's really pretty.
And then it gives you a
really nice visualization
of what's going on.
And you zoom in and out.
And it's pretty neat.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
enjoying saying Weaveworks.
MARK MANDEL: Weaveworks.
Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's a good name.
All right.
Well, Mark, are you
going to be anywhere
in the next couple weeks?
MARK MANDEL: I'm still
not traveling very much,
but I am actively
streaming a lot, which
has been lots of fun.
So you can find me on
Twitch.tv/markmandel.
I know you're popping
around and about.
What are you off to?
MELANIE WARRICK:
I will be speaking
at the Internet2 Global
Summit on May 9 in San Diego.
And then I'm going to be
talking at the Understand Risk
Forum on May 17 in Mexico City.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: And that's
where you can find me.
MARK MANDEL: Are you
speaking at Next,
since we're talking about Next?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
not, but are you?
MARK MANDEL: I am
speaking at Next.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey.
MARK MANDEL: So I'll be
speaking at Next [INAUDIBLE]
and talking about how you
can run game servers at scale
on top of open source software.
MELANIE WARRICK: Fabulous.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Melanie, thank you so
much for joining me
for yet another week.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]